big news for nintendo fans today as the  publisher has debuted the new Nintendo  2ds XL the handheld system will run you  a hundred and forty nine ninety-nine USD  and adopts the trusty clamshell design  you can pick it up in this fancy black  and turquoise design but there also  appears to be a white and orange option  but it's looking like that version may  not be making its way to the west the  new 2d s XL is arriving on July 28th  alongside the release of me topia and  hey Pikmin Nintendo have said the  console is lighter but just as powerful  as the new Nintendo 3ds XL hardware side  it features XL screens AC stick above  the face buttons the additional shoulder  buttons and has built-in NFC support for  amiibo cards and figures as you'd expect  the new device will be able to play the  entire library of prettiest and DS games  just not in 3d subscribe for all the  latest details on this one and let us  know what you think of the new 2d s XL  we'll catch you next time